X
COMMITTEE SAYS THIS COULD
HAPPEN IN AMERICA.
HE'S MY GUEST, LET'S GO OUT
FRONT.
GOOD EVENING, I AM ERIN
BURNETT.
UPFRONT TONIGHT, GAME-CHANGER,
CNN LEARNING EXCLUSIVELY THAT
UKRAINE WANTS DEADLY CLUSTER
MUNITION WARHEADS FROM THE U.S.
WEAPONS BANNED BY MORE THAN 100
COUNTRIES, THAT UKRAINE TONIGHT
SAYS WILL CHANGE THE COURSE OF
THE WAR.
THIS COMES AS PUTIN TONIGHT
PERSONALLY ESCALATES HIS
NUCLEAR THREAT.
>> >> TRANSLATOR: WITH REGARD
TO THE THREAT OF A NUCLEAR WAR,
YOU ARE RIGHT, THE THREAT IS
GROWING, SO WHY HIDE THE TRUTH?
NOW, REGARDING WHETHER OR NOT
RUSSIA WOULD BE THE FIRST TO
USE ONE, NO MATTER WHAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES BE, WELL, IF IT'S
NOT THE FIRST TO USE ONE, THEN
IT COULD NOT BE THE SECOND TO
USE ONE, BECAUSE A NUCLEAR
STRIKE ON OUR TERRITORY WOULD
GROUP LIMIT OUR CAPABILITIES.
>> PUTIN CLEARLY REFERRING TO
NUCLEAR ICBMS, NOT TACTICAL
NUKES, BECAUSE IT IS ICBMS THAT
RUSSIA AND THE U.S. HAD THAT
WOULD CAUSE SUCH DAMAGE AS TO
PREVENT A COUNTRY FROM
RESPONDING IN A SECOND STRIKE.
THAT'S A MAJOR THREAT, AND
PUTIN HAS THE LARGEST STOCKPILE,
ABOUT 4200 ICBM NUCLEAR
WARHEADS IN ADDITION TO HIS
ESTIMATED NEARLY 2000 TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
BUT PUTIN IS MAKING THIS THREAT,
COMING OUT AND PERSUADE DOING
IT WITH HIS BACK PRESSED FIRMLY
UP AGAINST THE WALL, BECAUSE HE
KNOWS HIS INVASION HAS NOT GONE
ACCORDING TO PLAN.
HE ALSO SAID TODAY, AND I QUOTE
HIM, REGARDING THE PROBLEM WITH
EQUIPMENT, AS FAR AS I CAN TELL,
THIS IS ALREADY BEEN SORTED
OUT.
HOWEVER, IF SOMETHING US NEEDS
ARE SPECIAL ATTENTION SOMEWHERE,
OF COURSE, I WOULD ASK FOR MORE
INFORMATION.
THEN WE WOULD DEFINITELY DEAL
WITH IT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND ADMISSION OF PROBLEMS WITH
EQUIPMENT, AS OFFICE THAT
MISSION MAY FEEL TO YOU, FOR
PUTIN TO SAY THIS, IT'S A BIG
DEAL.
HE IS FORCED TO EVEN ADMITTED
IT BECAUSE OF WHAT HIS SOLDIERS
ARE SEEING EVERY DAY AND ARE
NOW RECORDED ON TAPE TALKING
ABOUT.
WE HAVE BEEN SHARING
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN SOLDIERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES, AND I WANT
TO PLAY THIS FOR YOU, A NEWLY
OBTAINED CALL, RECENT CALL
BETWEEN A RUSSIAN SOLDIER AND
HIS MOTHER BACK HOME, LISTEN TO
IT.
>> >> TRANSLATOR: YOU HAVE
EVERYONE?
>> TRANSLATOR: LEAVING LEAVING
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING.
>> TRANSLATOR: LEAVING, LIKE
RUNNING AWAY?
>> TRANSLATOR: YES RUNNING AWAY
WHAT ELSE?
FIVE DAYS UNDER POURING RAIN
WITH NO SLEEP.
>> TRANSLATOR: THAT'S DESERTING,
WATCH OUT.
>> TRANSLATOR: IF THEY DON'T
LET US SLEEP IN DECEMBER, WILL
GO AWAY TO.
YOU JUST CAN'T IMAGINE, WE LIVE
IN A SWAMP, EVERYTHING IS
LEAKING.
WE HAVE NO SLEEP, NO FOOD,
NOTHING.
>> NO SLEEP, NO FOOD, NOTHING.
TIME IS CERTAINLY NO